walk him to this game the five-minute
game against grandmasters equal done 41
seconds sickened and 41 oh yeah Cobb
Murray that's funny that's a num all
time Grandmaster very creative player
his son yeah i think the sir z condiment
is referring to his role in the torch
noid cup of majesty was coach noisome
second and this is one of the lines that
they had prepared a kid scalp of played
by coach now in the match in 1978 and
known on the Philippines we didn't I not
i'm not sure ever played it correctly
let's see I think that maybe you should
have flicked in a six at some point yeah
this is a very weird form of a benoni
but it's interesting I have fun I have
looked at this type of positions in in
my my upcoming book and came to the
conclusion that quite often the son
needs to really unclear plain black
often gets the Bishop to b6 or c5 and
those nights do not yeah they are not in
house way they help to prevent the
advanced SEM he cannot so easily play me
five so let's see maybe get the Bishop
to b6 I must be a I must be cautious
about see form this must be well timed
and I should play it in the situation
where there's not no default possible
okay so it seems that his moving is
moving the night away so I maybe have
the opportunity to play ac4 then on f5
95 this is very nice and if I've I have
controlled so just just see for I might
I might play some more prep preparation
moves preparatory moves very difficult
word for a German tongue ok night h form
that's not leading to much i wonder if
he's got this I 5d takes a five business
but it does not look does not look very
dangerous I want to have a 5 b-4 also
the rock is not bad on be aid that was
the point
not sure that I want to trade Queens
really i'm taking with the rock on b6
looks a bit bit strange okay let's sum
gain some more space here that's not
does not hurt and before might be might
be useful and taking okay I thought I
have before now and ce4 okay this do i
do I my mum is playing that completely
on what is the point I don't don't
understand it really I thought this
would be quite nice for me with c4
coming okay you can take a day 5s
hanging okay this is the real point I
see should I maybe play b3 and some
break up the center
okay but i can i can do that it's not
it's not the problem he takes with the
rook at the end i have p 3 and the the
bishop only has be one we should be one
and i retreat the row can take b5 next
it should be should be okay I hope I
just retreat the rock now this is not
protected I might go to a forum now i
will look that okay then let's let's
switch things that then let's switch
plans IAM attacking into this way Roxy
one maybe yeah I screwed the sample I
really did i do i really like my
position early am but this this now is
very very tricky I mean tricky is the
wrong word I'm just goes quite clearly
probably I still have some active play
but it's not not really good of course
how to maybe muddy the waters h5 yeah h5
h4 right h5 taking the center this is
not a king cytotec i just want to h4
threaten c4 night moves night XD form as
it's not not entirely clear
ok tengo night f5 because there's a maid
on g7 hmm I guess he didn't didn't
already see that
don't really I don't really have some I
don't have anything concrete you in
terms of counter play I really don't
preparing 97 it is just to a stronger
piece probably yeah this is gambling a
bit I hope he does not take on d6 I just
can
night h5 maybe no maybe now night h5
taking the spawn this was this was
certainly some progress for me
20 seconds chime warning check hmm
really exchanging this as was was not
necessary check check check I can just
take it check check check check check
check check check check oops check white
dwarf it on time what the heck happened
ah I have no idea what was going on I
have what happed 15 100 yeah damn and I
wasn't even a pawn down so I didn't
really check check point in offering
channel check I can just take the Queen
yeah it's just that it's just a bunch of
pre moves ah so what was my problem here
I really thought that this should be ok
but it probably oh I have a win IAM a
director in the computer of course 95
mmm yeah the side of course didn't think
about it all and it's it's a direct win
wow yeah this is the problem here
and then winning the Queen yeah this is
this destroys white completely he has no
move and threatening to take and place
you for okay this I didn't didn't see of
course at all I was I have what I
underestimated really my initial idea
was to just retreat the rope here I was
I wanted to do that but it's not really
helping I mean you can even play here
I'm not sure what it well what what what
my improvement is and here calluses I
can go here just attacking this I
thought it would be helpful in this
Bishop personal square but simply cannot
I cannot keep this pawn maybe there's
some slight improvement at some point
but why does just clearly better him
yeah I was struggling on yeah this is
this now I don't really him I mean now I
have some play with the night but um
yeah you should be five probably winning
very messy very messy game for the lucky
end thanks for watching